so in there I get me kidney our flesh
kidney liver liver I'm Betty
and you cooking everything the same time
see normally we'd cook this separately
it's very rustic
Joey nothing's fileted nothing's ever
off my boat and what's that dad's
putting there my father is putting
another kind of live which you find the
force now what's it like thank you
that's quite citrasena
yeah yeah that's like lavender we use
even the fruits for black pepper
what's that day with the chilies he's
roasted we have a better flaring if we
roast it on the ash like that yeah it
gives a better scent yeah well we got we
do the same with peppers yeah that's a
fascinating smell how'd you know that
slightly spicy edge to it
pure Philip just a little touch then
trig me the flavor that you know
how'd you turn up the gas thank you
how many Westerners have come and cook
in this kitchen
none know I'm the first mmm it's a
tradition in Scotland wheels have a swig
age oh yes we're darling oh yeah
it means our passion has joined you the
dish the pork is delicious very tasty
the chilli the garlic and it looked
quite sort of boring and greasing the
flavour wife delicious
that's delicious the pork very nice
happy yes Jordan yeah can you just give
them a second he'll pickles
Oh
my father good boy shooter hey I don't
see your edges the poke dish I tasted of
theirs was amazing you'd think that
there was 15 different spices the dried
bamboo in terms of flavor it's intense
yet has an intriguing sort of turnip
stroke cardamon sort of slightly spicy
edge to it who would ever believe we're
in India no spice turmeric yeah no
coriander no cinnamon no clothes
everything's just yeah from the ground